on me demande très souvent pourquoi
l'enseigné
la grammaire aux enfants comme
on l'enseignait comme nous l'avons
appris nous comme on l'enseigné il ya 30
ans 40 en cinq ans même comment se
fait-il qu'on n'apprend plus la
grammaire de la même façon on me dit ah
nous nous apprenions les adjectifs les
adjectifs possessifs mom à mon lion de
belfort
nous apprenions les adjectifs
démonstratif ce c7 ce lion de belfort
des adjectifs indéfini certains quelques
bon maintenant vous parler déterminant
puis ailleurs de predica puis ailleurs
au lieu de parler de compléments
circonstanciels vous parlez de
complément de phrases et puis d'aspects
du verbe de thèmes de propos de
cohérence de cohésion qu'est ce que
c'est que tout ce bazar
comment se fait-il que vous n'utilisiez
plus les mots que nous n'utilisions que
nous utilisions les règles que nous
avons apprises pourtant la langue elle
n'a pas changé c'est toujours la langue
de molière et à cette question je
réponds souvent par une plaisanterie qui
est de dire que avant la terre elle
était plate
mais depuis qu'elle est devenue ronde eh
bien on a dû s'adapter un petit peu nous
avons dû changer notre vocabulaire
alors bien sûr c'est une plaisanterie
mais finalement pas tout à fait en effet
la grammaire c'est une description
alors certes c'est une description de la
langue
s'interroge sur les règles qui la font
fonctionner c'est une modélisation
s'interroge sur comment les mots les uns
après les voeux avec les autres
s'organisent comment on peut déterminer
des constances dans le fonctionnement de
la langue mais c'est aussi une réflexion
une analyse sur le fonctionnement de la
parole mais aussi plus généralement du
langage de notre capacité à communiquer
et nos conceptions de cette relation
entre le langage notre faculté à
communiquer ses implications
cérébral par exemple est la langue
change change beaucoup
c'est un phénomène très complexe que
nous avons devant nous et ce phénomène
très complexe il fonctionne donc par des
descriptions les règles de grammaire
mais ces règles de grammaire elles sont
toujours partiels elles sont toujours
incomplète
elles sont toujours oublieuse de
certains phénomènes
c'est ce que le grammairien américain
noam chomsky appelé le défi galiléen
c'est d'essayer de trouver des règles
suffisamment général qui exclut certes
certains phénomènes mais qu'ils puissent
être justement suffisamment efficace
pour pouvoir décrire véritablement ce
qui se passe dans une langue
alors pourquoi galilée et bien galilée
en son siècle 1630 par là il est
condamné en 1633 par la papauté galilée
il a devant lui
toutes sortes de phénomènes il a devant
lui toutes sortes d'expériences et la
cohérence globale qu'on peut trouver
entre toutes ces expériences et bien il
ne l'a pas il insiste m devant lui qui a
l'air complexe mais les causes qu'il
peut apporter pour expliquer ce système
est bien seco sont extrêmement
difficiles à trouver et le défi de
galilée a été de considérer que ce
problème massif global on devait le café
on devait le séparer en plusieurs
questions et on devait accepter
d'éliminer certains problèmes de ne pas
en tenir compte
galilée dans l'imagerie populaire dans
les idées et que nous avons gardé les
représentations que nous avons gardé de
lui il est au dessus de la tour de pise
et il
jettent des cailloux alors pourquoi vous
avez ici de représentation une ancienne
une moderne
ils jettent des cailloux pour regarder
aux tombes où tombent les pierres quand
on jette un objet ou est ce qu'il tombe
et on fait toutes sortes
d'expérimentations à son époque pour
savoir comment tombe un corps parce
qu'on suppose que si on jette quelque
chose ou si on lâche quelque chose
si en même temps la terre elle se
déplace la chose en question bien elle
va tomber plus ou moins la verticale
plus ou moins à droite plus ou moins à
gauche si je jette quelque chose en
l'air et que je me déplace en même temps
parce que quelque chose il va tomber à
côté de moi donc on fait toutes sortes
d'expériences et certaine expérience
donne des idées à galilée des théories
certaine expérience du verbe est de
construire un système la terre elle
tourne mais sur cette terre des objets
sont cohérents ils sont solidaires on
jette quelque chose eh bien il retombe
sur nous mais parallèlement il ya
d'autres expériences
il ya d'autres expériences qui sont fait
des expériences avec des canons on tire
au canon et qu'est-ce qui se passe est
ce que le boulaire tombe sur nous la
terre est immobile ou alors tout est
cohérent
ou alors on tire au canon la terre se
déplace le bullet on d'un côté ou de
l'autre
ces expériences ne donne pas des
résultats qui sont analysable à l'époque
de galilée égaliser n'arrive pas à
trouver une cohérence et bien en
grammaire en grammaire ans fonctionne
toujours en sciences en généralement
grammaire ans fonctionne aussi comme
cela c'est à dire que nous avons des
phénomènes mais ces phénomènes nous n'en
trouvons pas forcément les règles
parfaite de fonctionnement nous n'en
trouvons pas spécifiquement pour
l'ensemble du système
les règles d'autant que nos
connaissances sur le langage progresse
progresse ou ne progresse pas
la première grammaire modernes que nous
avons eu les premiers grammairien ils
sont nés de la suite de la réflexion de
galilée lorsque des philosophes comme
rené descartes se sont intéressés au
langage et on envisager justement les
problèmes dans leur globalité mais aussi
dans leurs subdivisions à la suite de
rené descartes et de la fameuse phrase
qu'il le prononce
je pense donc je suis les grammairiens
se sont dit qu'il y avait une relation
entre la pensée mais on ne sait pas très
bien comment elle fonctionne et lettres
l'individu je suis en ont déduit que
pour décrire une langue fallait penser
que tous les verbes était finalement des
verbes être plus quelque chose je suis
je pense donc je suis donc je suis ici
en train de parler je suis en train de
manger je mange je suis en train de
dormir je dors bon on pensait qu'il y
avait une relation entre la pensée et la
longue donc la grammaire elle devait
décrire cette relation évidemment cette
idée elle a progressé elle s'est
transformée quand nous avons fait des
progrès sur la conception de ce qu'est
la pensée mais donc ce qu'est le langage
si je fais un saut deux mille ans avant
nous je m'aperçois que aristote plus de
2000 ans avait déjà défini dépenses et
relevant de catégorie catégorie
l'entendement y pensait que la pensée
finalement elle relevé deux grandes
directions dix catégories
et quand on parlait qu'est ce que l'on
quand on parle qu'est ce que l'on fait
bon puise voilà dans ces catégories
il pensait que la grammaire et bien elle
devait décrire comme on puisait dans les
catégories qu'étaient les catégories de
la pensée alors le défi galiléen qu'est
ce que c'est c'est se dire qu'il y a des
dimensions qui nous échappe mais qu'il
faut construire une pensée une pensée
qui explique
il faut s'appuyer sur l'expérience il
faut s'appuyer sur des raisonnements
mais des raisonnements qui puisque le
système global et bloqué des
raisonnements qui exclut certaines
parties et on espère que les parties que
l'on a exclu et bien ne sont pas
suffisamment importante pour mettre
notre raisonnement au cloud cloud voilà
un mot intéressant cloud un clou c'est
loin des clous celle aux us vous avez
appris le pluriel des morons ou mais
vous avez tous appris quelque chose
d'autre qu'il y en a d'autres qui
fonctionne différemment
yves ou cailloux sous genoux vous l'avez
appris ça des grammairiens abandonnés
ils ont dit on va isoler un phénomène on
va prendre des mots ils répondront pas à
la règle alors pourquoi quand la règle
s'est défini les grammairiens se sont
dit ouh là attention chaud en ancien
français ça se disait schuhl bien elle
au bout et puis genou ça se disait jean
noël lien elle au bout et puis cailloux
ça se disait shy noces il ya des ailes
et qu'est ce qu'on a dit cheval il ya l
on va le faire en chevaux avec un x
vitrail y aller au bout on va le faire
en vitraux avec un x bats ces mots là on
va leur mettre un x aussi yves ou chou
genou cailloux et tous les autres on a
isolé un phénomène et on essaie de
trouver une explication ponctuelles dans
un cadre mais après est-ce que le monde
change à cette explication tient
toujours
il y à milan on avait mal au jeune homme
il ya mille ans la terre était plate
puis d'un seul coup et s'est arrondi
d'un seul coup le elle
il a disparu ces pages nord il ses
genoux mais le x lui il est resté mais
que vaut-il dire maintenant seuls hics
est-ce que
quelqu'un vous a dit qu'on apprenait
iboucherie genou caillou avec un x parce
qu'il y avait mille ans il y avait à l
aube ou du mot ça veut rien dire du tout
il ya mille ans la terre était plate
donc parfois les grammairiens son prix
d'un fruit son aile ce disque décidément
il faut transformer ces règles que nous
avons hérité ils se disent que
l'explication que l'on donnait a certes
permis d'avancer a certes permis de
comprendre mieux notre langue mais
maintenant les recherche en
neurobiologie en bio linguistique en
physiologie sur le fonctionnement de la
pensée donc du langage donc
l'organisation des langues font que
parfois on se dit que les explications
que nous avions peuvent entrer dans des
mécanismes plus globaux que maintenant
on peut comprendre
et quand galilée exclut par exemple de
ces théories le fait que quand on jette
un objet quand on tire au canon l'objet
retombe plus tôt à l'est
il faudra attendre deux siècles avec
coriolis pour comprendre ce qui se passe
là donc parfois on fait des descriptions
provisoire et deux siècles après elle
c'est clair
donc oui nous n'apprenons plus tout à
fait la grammaire de la même façon mais
parce que la grammaire et versaient une
description et cette description elle
essaie de penser comment la langue elle
s'organise en fonction de l'état de nos
connaissances de l'humain mais aussi de
son fonctionnement cérébral ils étaient
donc une fois la grammaire française
mais il y aura encore dans l'avenir des
grammaire française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]